.
>> Jessica: THAT WAS GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS AFTER DAMAGE
IN FLORIDA.
A MAJOR ESCALATION ON THE WAR IN
UKRAINE COME UP VLADIMIR PUTIN
DECLARED 40,000 SQUARE MILES AS
PART OF RUSSIA.
EXPERTS SAY THE LARGEST LAND
GRAB SINCE WORLD WAR II.
THE U.S. AND ALLIES RESPONDED BY
SLAPPING A NEW ROUND OF
SANCTIONS ON RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
HERE IS PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> PUTIN ACTIONS ARE A SIGN HE
STRUGGLING.
THE UNITED STATES WILL NEVER
RECOGNIZE THIS.
QUITE FRANKLY, THE WORLD IS NOT
GOING TO RECOGNIZE IT EITHER.
HE CAN'T SEES HIS NEIGHBOR'S
TERRITORY AND GET AWAY WITH
THIS.
IT IS AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
AMERICAS FULLY PREPARED TO OUR
NATO ALLIES TO DEFEND EVERY
SINGLE INCH OF NATO TERRITORY.
>> Jessica: PERHAPS MORE
CONCERNING DURING PUTIN
'UNHINGED SPEECH HE CREATED --
NUCLEAR WEAPONS BY PALM IN
JAPAN.
HE SAID LAST WEEK HE WAS NOT
LOVING WHEN IT COMES TO USING
NUKES TO DEFEND HIS TERRITORY,
DANA.
I WANT TO COME TO YOU ON THIS.
IT FEELS LIKE MORE THAN JUST AN
ESCALATION.
WE USE THAT TERM ALL THE TIME.
IT IS REALLY A DEPARTURE.
>> Dana: YOU CALL IT A STEP
CHANGE I BELIEVE.
I WAS ABLE TO TALK TO SOME FOLKS
THAT I TRUST ON THIS.
THEY THINK THIS IS THE MOST
DANGEROUS PART OF THE SITUATION
THAT WE HAVE BEEN IN BECAUSE
ONE, PUTIN HAS PAINTED HIMSELF
INTO THE CORNER.
HE HAS VERY FEW FRIENDS.
HIS COUNTRY IS UNHAPPY.
THE PEOPLE ARE UNHAPPY WITH THE
CALL UP AND I THINK WE'VE HAD UP
TO -- PERHAPS AS MANY AS 3,000
MEN TRYING TO LEAVE RUSSIA.
SOME OF THE RUSSIAN MEN HAVE
BROKEN THEIR OWN BONES IN ORDER
TO AVOID HAVING TO GO AND FIGHT.
THEY ARE REPORTING FROM UKRAINE
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN ORDERED TO
KILL CIVILIANS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO DO IT, AND
THEIR HEART IS NOT IN IT.
THE UKRAINIANS HEART IS IN IT.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO WOULD TAKE
OVER IF THERE WAS TO BE SOMEBODY
ELSE.
SOMETIMES IT IS BETTER THAN WHEN
YOU KNOW THAN THE ONE YOU DON'T.
BUT I BELIEVE
PRESIDENT BIDEN, HE IS BEING AS
STRONG AS HE POSSIBLY CAN, I
SUPPOSE.
BUT I HAVE LONG THOUGHT THAT YOU
HAVE TO ASK IS EUROPE GOING TO
SAVE ITSELF?
IS EUROPE WILLING TO SAVE
ITSELF?
WE CAN BE THERE AS WELL AND
BIDEN CAN SAY THAT, BUT WHO IS
THE FACE OF THIS FIGHT FOR THE
EUROPEANS?
AND WHO WILL STEP UP AND WHO
WILL THAT BE?
THEY HAVE A LOT OF ECONOMIC
PROBLEMS THAT THEY WERE DEALING
WITH PEER THEY HAVE A HUGE
ENERGY CRISIS THIS YEAR.
THEY ALSO ARE TIMID.
SOME OF THEM ARE TIMID TO GET
THE COMMITMENTS OF THE WEAPONS
TO THE UKRAINIANS.
TO GERMANY IN PARTICULAR.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
BIDEN CAN DO BEHIND THE SCENES
IS YOU NEEDS TO PRESS THE
EUROPEANS TO BE MORE WILLING TO
STEP UP AND BE THE FACE OF THIS
SO THAT PUTIN DOESN'T THINK THIS
IS A WAR WITH THE UNITED STATES.
THIS IS A WAR THAT HE CHOSE AND
THAT THE UKRAINIANS DECIDED TO
FIGHT BACK.
THEY HAVE A CHOICE, TOO AND IN
THAT SITUATION BECAUSE THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE BEEN WELL.
AT THIS MOMENT, PROBABLY A MORE
DANGEROUS SOUND THAT WE HAVE
EVER BEEN SINCE FEBRUARY.
>> Jessica: JESSE, WHAT DO YOU
THINK ABOUT THAT AND THIS
MORNING LENSKI SIGNED THE
PAPERWORK TO FAST TRACK
APPLICATION TO NATO?
>> Jesse: THAT WILL GET
REJECTED BUT I SPOKE TO PEOPLE
ON THIS AT THE SAME THING THAT
DANA'S SOURCES ARE SAYING.
PUTIN IS SPEAKING TO SIX PEOPLE
I'M TOLD AND HE DEMANDS THAT
THEY LIE TO HIM SO HE'S NOT
GETTING AN ACCURATE PICTURE WHAT
IS HAPPENING ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
AND, THERE IS NO WAY THAT WE ARE
GOING TO SETTLE ON
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S TERMS.
HE HAS KILLED A QUARTER OF A
MILLION CIVILIANS AND HAS
KIDNAPPED ABOUT A MILLION
UKRAINIANS.
AND YOU THINK HE'S GOING TO SAY
ALL RIGHT, LET'S NEGOTIATE.
WE WILL JUST USE UKRAINE AS A
BUFFER.
U.S. POLICY AND EUROPEAN
POLICIES TOWARD RUSSIA RIGHT NOW
IS A COMPLETE AND TOTAL
DESTRUCTION OF RUSSIA.
THEY ARE COPING WITH UKRAINIANS
AND THEY ARE GOING TO EXPEL ALL
RUSSIAN FORCES FROM UKRAINE.
THEY WILL DEMAND REPAYMENT TO
BUILD EVERYTHING IN UKRAINE.
THERE WILL BE A WARM CRIMES
TRIBUNAL TO HOLD ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
MASSIVE CIVILIANS THAT THEY HAVE
SLAUGHTERED.
YOU ARE NOT JUST GOING TO INVADE
THIS COUNTRY, COMMIT ATROCITIES
AND WALK AWAY AFTER DESTROYING
THE ENTIRE INTERNATIONAL SUPPLY
CHAIN.
DESTROYING THE ENERGY MARKETS IN
EUROPE.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE KIDDING ME.
SO THE GUY, HE IS GOING TO LOSE
THIS, AND IT IS NOT LOOKING
GOOD.
>> Jessica: WILL HE USE NUKES?
>> Dagen: A POSSIBILITY OR
POTENTIAL OF AN ESCALATION AND
AT THE VERY LEAST TACTICAL
NUCLEAR STRIKE.
TO DANA'S POINT, WEEK, I SEE THE
WEST BUT WE THE EUROPE AND THE
UNITED STATES, WE HAVE NOT
STARVED PUTIN OF MONEY OR
MANPOWER.
EUROPE CAN HELP OUT BY OPENING
UP THE COUNTRIES TO ALL OF THE
RUSSIANS AND RUSSIAN TRYING TO
GET AWAY FROM VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
TAKE THEM DRAFT DODGERS AND MAKE
THEM REFUGEES, OPEN THE DOORS IN
A LOT OF COUNTRIES ARE REFUSING
TO DO THAT OR DRAGGING THEIR
FEET ON THAT.
BUT ALSO, WE HAVEN'T DONE
ANYTHING TO BANKRUPT PUTIN'S
REGIME.
BUT WE ARE NOT WILLING, THE
POLITICIANS AREN'T WILLING TO
RISK A RECESSION FOR A NUCLEAR
CONFLICT SOMEHOW IS A RISK WORTH
TAKING A QUESTION MARK THAT IS
WHERE WE ARE.
WE NEED TO DRIVE DOWN THE PRICE
OF NATURAL GAS.
THAT DOES MEAN MORE SUPPLY, BUT
IT ALSO MEANS CRUSHING AND
CRIPPLING DEMAND LIKE IT
HAPPENED DURING COVID.
WE HAVE NOT DONE THAT.
WE ARE ACTUALLY DOING THE EXACT
OPPOSITE TO DRIVE UP DEMAND FOR
FUEL.
CALIFORNIA IS GETTING READY TO
SEND CHECKS TO HALF THE PEOPLE
IN THE STATE.
OH, BECAUSE OF THE HIGH GAS
PRICES, YOU NEED MORE MONEY.
NO, THAT DOESN'T HURT DEMAND AND
OVER IN EUROPE JUST TO NAME ONE,
BRITAIN IS CAPPING HOUSEHOLD
ENERGY BILLS?
SO YOU CAN USE AS MUCH ENERGY AS
YOU WANT, ANYTHING IN EXCESS OF
THE CAP, WE WILL SEND MONEY TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THAT IS IRRETRIEVABLY WRONGFUL.
>> Jessica: GREG.
>> Greg: I WAS CONFUSED WHEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID IT WAS NATO
TERRITORY.
>> Dana: THEY THINK PUTIN IS
THREATENING NATO COUNTRIES WITH
THE WORD OF.
>> Greg: THAT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO ME.
IT IS A SHAM ANNEXATION AND NO
ONE IS TAKING IT SERIOUSLY.
I NEVER HEARD OF THESE PLACES
TEN MONTHS AGO.
I DO KNOW IN OUR COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW, WE ARE GOING THROUGH SOME
VERY, VERY SERIOUS TIMES.
WE JUST TALKED ABOUT THE CRIME.
WE HAVE INFLATION IN OUR ECONOMY
IS.
IT IS LIKE ALL THAT IS CHANGING
WITH THIS IS THAT WE KEEP
SENDING BILLIONS AND BILLIONS
AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THERE.
ALL WE ARE DOING IS NOT
AFFECTING THE OUTCOME BUT WE ARE
AFFECTING THE DURATION.
AND SO ALL WE ARE DOING IS
MAKING IT LONGER BUT WE HAVE A
SENSE WE KNOW HOW IT WILL END
APPEAR THERE WAS NO WAY PUTIN
WILL GET THERE.
HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT IS PEOPLE.
SPEAKING PEOPLE, THERE IS A
GENERATION GAP AND HALF OF THE
PEOPLE, MORE THAN HALF OF THE
PEOPLE PUTIN, OLDER GENERATIONS
LIKE HIM BECAUSE HE'S BEEN
AROUND.
THEY CAN BRAINWASH THE YOUNGER
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE LEAVING.
SO, I DON'T THINK HE HAS ANY
REASON TO WORRY.
SO WE ARE AT THIS POINT WHERE I
THINK THE REPUBLICANS AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE IN AGREEMENT AND
TERMS OF WAR BUT NOT IN TERMS OF
PEACE.
THIS IS WHERE MY CRAZY IDEA IS
THAT IT WOULD BE REALLY NICE TO
SEE SOMEBODY LIKE TRUMP AND
OBAMA TOGETHER DOING SOMETHING
LIKE TOGETHER AND TRYING TO HELP
NEGOTIATE SOME KIND OF PEACE.
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE.
IT IS ABSURD, IT IS A CRAZY IDEA
BUT NOT AS CRAZY THINKING MAN
CAN GET PREGNANT.
[LAUGHTER]
IF YOU WANT TO LAUGH AT THE IDEA
OF TWO PRESIDENTS TO I AM IN TO
I AM IN A DIAMETRICALLY OPPOSED
COMING TOGETHER AND TROMPED
CALLING IN, OBAMA, THAT IS NOT A
GOOD SIGN BUT LOOK, MAYBE I
COULD TALK TO PUTIN AND YOU CAN
TALK TO ZELENSKYY.
YOU THINK THAT IS CRAZY, THEN
WHAT IDEAS DO YOU HAVE?
>> Jesse: FORGET ABOUT WHAT I
SAID ABOUT YOUR BIRTH
CERTIFICATE.
[LAUGHTER]
I WILL APOLOGIZE FOR SPYING ON
YOUR CAMPAIGN.
WE WILL FLY TO YOUR.
>> Greg: EXACTLY!
EVER SINGLE CUP BUDDY FILM THEY
ALWAYS WIN IN THE END.
>> LETHAL WEAPON, 48 HOURS, RUSH
HOUR.
THE POINT IS NOBODY IS TALKING
ABOUT NEGOTIATION.
NOBODY IS TALKING ABOUT OFF
RAMPS.
AND I THINK THERE MIGHT BE AN
OFF-RAMP WITH THE OLIGARCHS TO
SEE THEIR MONEY, TRULY
FRIGHTENING.
THEY ARE GETTING KILLED, THE
OLIGARCHS ARE GETTING KILLED.
THERE MIGHT BE AN EXIT STRATEGY
THEY CREATE FOR PUTIN AND
GUARANTEED TO KEEP ALL YOUR
MONEY, WE WILL NOT KILL YOUR
SECRETARY.
WE WILL NOT KILL ANYBODY BUT YOU
GET TO GO -- AND THEY WOULD HAVE
TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE YOU WON
SOMETHING, DON BASS, YOU KNOW.
MAYBE THAT'S WHAT THEY GIVE
THEM.
>> Jesse: BUT THEY ARE NOT
GIVING THEM ANYTHING.
>> Greg: I KNOW, I KNOW.
WE WILL GIVE THEM BILLIONS AND
THE OUTCOME WILL BE, DESTROY A
COUNTRY, UKRAINE.
>> Jessica: THAT IS
INTERESTING BECAUSE ZELENSKYY IS
THE ONE HARDEN TO NEGOTIATION.
HE SAID I WILL NEVER DO IT WITH
HIM.
BEFORE HE WAS FOR NEGOTIATION...
>> Jessica: RIGHT, BUT A LOT
OF PEOPLE DIED SINCE THE